all right
[Applause]
Matthew
all right
thank you very much look at you taking
it all in yes as your mayor I want to
welcome all of you
you know I I could use your advice
actually it's so nice that you could be
here and uh I could use your advice
because I'm it's a much different venue
that I'm used to playing we're usually
in a much smaller television Studio this
is a giant theater you are a Broadway
Pro what's the secret to performing in
this space
well well you know typically the
gestures are larger and faces are
broader everything must be able to be
read from very far away right because
people aren't there's some people right
here but they're also people sitting way
in the back and they might not
if I do this or make a little motion
bigger I think it's much bigger yes
I don't know if you can see we actually
I'll show you what it's like from their
point of view if they really don't have
the best view
of what's Happening look at that
we could
yeah that's unfortunate
well there you know thanks for coming
yeah thanks for being here we could be
on fire right now and they would not
know it yes I was once uh you know when
I was first started acting I mean on
stage nobody tells you how to do it and
though I was once watching uh daytime I
was watching TV and Rex Harrison was on
the great Rex Harrison of my fair lady
yes yeah and he taught me which I do how
to act on stage which is which is that
the foot this foot points at you and
this foot points to the audience
and this one goes in the pocket and I
gesture with his hand
I should interview you like that but in
this space yes Matthew so good to have
you here thank you I'm glad to be here
you've got to love the city of New York
yes
what are you doing oh okay all right uh
do you um you know it's funny you live
in this town with your yeah
it scared me yeah like a guy on the
subway
like New York you know New York
instincts you you're so terrible ideas
calm down he's with me he's okay like I
snuck up on you wow
he's a little close isn't he he's really
in a oh now oh
um can we borrow your New York Post
there Mr Robert if you're talking to
more than one person on stage what do
you point at them yeah
he didn't say Chris Harrison didn't say
wow